what's up my babies it's episode 169 of
congratulations
[Music]
yeah man took his final sips of water
right at that countdown dude I took it I
was like I like I drank it a little bit
of water and then the [ __ ] countdown
was happening he goes three and my
technician goes two and while fired goes
want and even you know they do it when
they do it when they're like and here we
go in three five four three that's like
just say the number it's fine if
everyone hears you say two one you know
but anyway how was your 4/20 dude did
you toke it up did you [ __ ] get faded
did you did you smoke that sticky icky
did you [ __ ] take that chocolate ty
did you do the that purple or Apple did
you did you smoke that magic good I got
[ __ ] high as [ __ ] dude you know me I
got high woke up rolled over ate a
brownie and just [ __ ] took it to lala
land
dude I just took it to lala land all day
man and I was token and smoking [ __ ] man
did some heroin did some [ __ ]
shooting and sand sucking with my nose I
don't give a [ __ ] I was high as [ __ ] 420
with weed coke cocaina and all that [ __ ]
man I [ __ ] can't get enough of it
it's the only day I do drugs 4/20 I do
all the drugs I've ever seen you know
I've never done drugs okay and I'm being
silly because this is a [ __ ] silly
podcast don't ever take what I'm saying
for real but you know what is the truth
is I definitely I definitely put up an
Instagram the other day about how I was
token and it was something that bleach
media made they made a lot of mimic a
lot of funny content on Instagram and I
did a thing where I unwrapped a candy
and ate a candy and it was just a
regular candy it was a regular chocolate
candy to understand and [ __ ] uh
bleach media made it so it was a joint
and put a [ __ ] Rastafarian hat on me
and it was
and the music was playing boom boom done
you know that one reggae song that's
every song that's that one reggae song
that's every year reggae song and it was
going wrong and then I ate the candy but
look there was smoking a joint and I
posted that and it looks at ridiculous
okay and somebody writes dude I thought
you said you didn't smoke
I thought you say you didn't do drugs on
Netflix I thought you said you didn't do
drugs in your last stand-up special and
I was like yeah well it's fake and also
the hats fake to my really smoking that
cartoon blunt and then I said eh it's a
fake blunt and also the the hats fake
and then some guy goes like this
actually it's a spliff hey it's nothing
hey it's actually nothing though ah dude
this is it man it's the real world
coming right coming live at you at the
real world it's Chris D'Elia here
bringing you the real world and the real
content that you need [ __ ] NPR you know
how we do but yeah man it's
congratulations episode number 169 I
can't believe how many [ __ ] episodes
I did I did I I went on a campaign blitz
dude my special came out holy [ __ ] man I
never had this many eyeballs on anything
I did except for maybe that show you I
can't believe how many people visited my
profile and [ __ ] it's crazy that so
actually overwhelming and thank you to
everybody who watched my Netflix special
no pain I really appreciate you guys you
know I can't thank you enough I love
doing it I love doing stand-up it's my
whole life and for everybody that
continues to watch me do the [ __ ]
genuinely thank you from the bottom of
my heart and in the meantime since we
can't do stand-up we're doing this
podcast and I find fun doing the podcast
too but if it doesn't grow you know I'll
pull the plug if the podcast doesn't get
bigger and bigger if it doesn't get the
[ __ ] wave going and then if it trends
down fine but I better hit that second
wave like the coronavirus they said
they're gonna be two three waves and
that the second waves gonna be worse and
the third way cool ava is not going to
be as bad as the first or second
wave and that's what happened in the
Spanish flu and that's what also is
gonna happen with the [ __ ] with that
Rona
so you know I don't know if it's so
[ __ ] it's so it's so horrible to have
to not ever do anything but I'm here for
your babies and just keep listening man
we're growing this cold weather we can
go outside or not we're growing this
cult period but thank you for staying in
and watching well you had to stay and
well thank you for staying safe really
and you had to watch and you watched no
pain and that [ __ ] hit number four on
Netflix for two days in a row and then I
think the next day was like number nine
or something that's just a lot of
eyeballs man I've never been so visual
it's very overwhelming you know I
thought it's gonna be a party man I
thought I was gonna be like my specials
out but I got like [ __ ] you know
overwhelmed man the human in me started
to [ __ ] crack and I'm just like man
everybody's watching y'all watching
though so anyway 4/20 took the [ __ ]
steak sting out of that when I took that
little bit of that sticky icky that
little oh wait that little purple urple
that magic dust and then [ __ ] sniff
some Bolivian marching powder where's it
marching all the way up my [ __ ] nose
damped up the babe that the babe of the
babe of the babe of the bainham is that
a [ __ ] is that from something I feel
like that's from something I don't know
um but yeah dude we're [ __ ] doing it
and guess what man it's the nighttime
podcast now this is the third nighttime
podcast we've had in a row and your boy
fires on all cylinders because that's
when he performs but I can't do this I
can't do the podcast at [ __ ] night
time because I'm usually doing stand-up
but that [ __ ] rona ruined all that
the [ __ ] bacteria and the viruses
[ __ ] all that up so your boys live and
[ __ ] in his goddamn basement just
crushing it you know maybe you're
laughing maybe or not I don't know dude
I don't know maybe you're laughing maybe
or not but either way I can't hear you
so it doesn't [ __ ] matter
sup would you know who started that
coronavirus is zoom the makers of zooms
started that coronavirus that [ __ ] is
insane how many everyone's like you zoom
dude the second somebody coughed it just
went and someone went you want to zoom
and now everybody does [ __ ] zoom
it's unbelievable everyone zuman people
do got no business zoom in there zoom in
there like you want to zoom I'm like
what happened a FaceTime oh yea soom now
I did a zoom with [ __ ] eight comic
buddies it was funny [ __ ] man we roasted
each other you weren't invited but it's
all good maybe we'll do that maybe we'll
let like a few fans and that would be
hilarious man me Andrew Santino and a
bunch of others and just zoom in with
some fans roastin I gotta make this
money though the problem is I can't make
money on any new [ __ ] unless some of the
pro teets proceeds go to like [ __ ]
masks or some [ __ ] so I got a [ __ ]
and figure out how I'm gonna help the
world you know your boy has got to help
the world I got to help the world more
man I really do you know people I got to
help the world more I got to start I got
to start some fund or some [ __ ] I got to
start a foundation is what I got to do
and I'll tell you what else I got to do
is stop eating these [ __ ] cookies
later than I do it I finished Breaking
Bad yes whoa yo it's white my [ __ ] my
arms white is [ __ ] but it's also lumpy
you know what that means man your void
that some chin-ups yes why it doesn't go
outside because he's inside
don't chin ups I'm a [ __ ] prisoner
inside dude just wait have you seen
prisoners work out bro first of all
let's talk about Breaking Bad and I'm
talking about prisoners working out I
saw some prison workouts on YouTube and
it's unbelievable dude those
[ __ ] are the most fit jacked
dudes on the planet how come black dudes
in the prison are so jacked white dudes
in prison are either so frail or fatty
[ __ ] and all I mean it's unbelievable
dude white guys in prison if they're
jacked they're also fat they have a
belly black dudes they're so top-heavy
they're always running cuz I can't help
but cuz they're falling over to it I
can't believe black dudes in prison
they're so Jax is unbelievable but let's
talk about Breaking Bad I finally
watched it and this is very timely my
babies this is very timely I know the
[ __ ] show ended in 2013 7 years ago
but your boy just watched it I was
waiting for a time to watch it because I
don't watch shows like that
I don't just continually watch I don't
watch all seasons if anything the only
thing I've ever seen every episode of is
I actually missed one episode of Dexter
but besides that I seen the whole [ __ ]
on Dexter and let me tell you something
man I was talking
about this on the broken podcast I did
this lie did this last week we're
talking about about I think shows can
only be good for about five seasons
maybe six seasons dude but the second
you do your Walking Dead it the second
you're just like well let's just keep
going to keep making money and Rogan
brought up a popular a very good point
you don't want to end the show because
all these people working on it that's
their livelihood and you don't want to
end the show creatively just because
these other [ __ ]
that's that what they get their job
that's what they get their paycheck from
so you got a guy who's holding the
[ __ ] mic he's just like oh this is
the last season ok cool guess I'll
[ __ ] sell my place like you don't
want the guy holding the thing or the
ladies holding the bagel putting out the
spread for craft service oh this is the
last season well ok I'll move to Van
Nuys oh this is the last season ok I'll
just move to the outskirts of Atlanta
you don't want to do that dude let me
tell you right now man let me tell you
right [ __ ] now if I ever get a show
on the air my show I'm talking about my
[ __ ] now we're on the lead where it's my
[ __ ] where I produce it ok um I'm doing
two things I'm doing one of two things
I'm either stopping it four seasons in
and getting the [ __ ] out and just making
some [ __ ] that hits the the zeitgeist
hopefully or I'm running that [ __ ] into
the ground I'm doing I'm talking I'm
talking about if it's a hit I'm doing 12
seasons and they're like well what do
you what do you think I said we got more
seasons really the lead character isn't
even in it anymore by the way nobody in
the original show is in the new SH is in
the show if it goes twelve seasons
they've all died either of [ __ ]
characters killing them or natural
causes in real life and we don't even
explain it they're just dead and we're
like oh new guys playing them now and
then that guy dies could we have to kill
off the character and then there's just
a new cast and the show becomes about
something else like dude if I was making
the Walking Dead
how's this for a [ __ ] YouTube clip
dude if I was making the Walking Dead
that [ __ ] lasts about six seasons and
then the [ __ ] cures I don't give a [ __ ]
what happened in the graphic novels it
doesn't matter I get it graphic novels
okay everyone's gonna be like oh yeah
but what about this no matter what it's
not true to them I don't give a [ __ ]
it's not
to it because this is a different medium
your boys different on his podcast that
he is in you that he is on stage and
stand up you want the raw real deal you
get it here you know what I mean
you want a hot flames performance to get
it there on stage if you want me tied up
act in my chops off dude then you turn
on you if I take a graphic novel like
[ __ ] Walking Dead and I do it for six
seasons in it becomes the biggest show
on television like it did guess what the
virus the seven seas season is cured and
then everyone starts to get new jobs and
then it becomes a [ __ ] office comedy
and if you think I'm [ __ ] a dude if
somebody did that dude that would be
unbelievable they all got real jobs and
now all of a sudden they're like working
construction and it becomes a [ __ ]
movie it becomes a TV show about like
the whoever the lead character is at
that point it has a construction job and
he's trying to keep his family afloat in
the [ __ ] times of of like and it's
just completely different show and and a
half the idiots out there don't even
know what the [ __ ] they're watching
anymore they're just like oh wait the
Walking Dead is all and I'm gonna change
the title to by that by the 11th season
I'm changing the goddamn title it's
called [ __ ] construction that is what
[ __ ] shows need to do stop drilling
it into the ground oh really
walkers oh they're walking around let me
guess someone gets bitten let me guess
on an all-new Walking Dead someone we
love gets bitten [ __ ] that cure the
virus and put them all in [ __ ] Kinkos
dude no more frigging zombies just hey
got those copies cool you know you're
gonna get fired if you keep on [ __ ]
up I know on an all-new Walking Dead
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's the guy's name Rick the main guy
on an all-new Walking Dead Rick gets his
pilot's license and starts flying for
American Airlines
alright you gotta buckle up hopefully
you got understand the [ __ ]
stewardesses and we swear now cuz it's
on a completely different channels on
HBO the [ __ ] stewardess is to come by
with drinks I'll take your order this is
a cashless system we need your call
harder with the chip we've got a four
hour and 12 minutes fly high which seems
to be the problem my Wi-Fi doesn't work
let me fix it whoops
boink falls cuz it's a [ __ ] comedy
about airplanes now dude [ __ ] your show
if it goes seven season seriously
Breaking Bad got in and out dude
Breaking Bad got in and out the [ __ ]
dude was a [ __ ] up chemistry teacher
Oh what do I do to save my family I know
I'll cook Matt BAM first season second
season oh [ __ ] I'm in over my head well
why don't I [ __ ] shave it BAM second
season he looks different third [ __ ]
thing oh no I'm in a whole [ __ ] thing
with this guy from Albuquerque and that
really [ __ ] proper guy named Joe
Carlo Esposito is just like I know who
you are and then [ __ ] what happens in
isn't over his head oh [ __ ] he can't get
out BAM four seasons now what happens
all the cancers gone and [ __ ] Aaron
Paul's in a basement somewhere BAM fifth
season now he's out for blood
he's up for blood because he has to kill
everybody that's it dude if AMC was like
dude we make we're gonna make you more
money and and you do more seasons than I
go like this well then guess what man
new characters new plot break it because
so call it break it bad I don't give a
[ __ ] it's about the [ __ ] shows about
a shark now in captivity
[Music]
[Applause]
so yeah I don't know I mean it's one
thing if it's a comfort show like if
it's like [ __ ] what do you call it
with the geeks
on the ABC the most successful show of
all time the geeks they should just call
that show geeks what the [ __ ] are
called with the guys who do the all the
dorks on the bazinga bazinga the [ __ ] is
it the guy won the Emmy for it Big Bang
Theory is uncultured folks Big Bang
Theory on CBS not on ABC and not called
the geeks oh man that's so awesome
Breaking Bad is the [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ]
you dude
you know and then people are like do you
see the wire though yeah I saw the wire
do it alright why don't you just [ __ ]
relax I saw the wire okay
it's good but relax you compare a show
to Breaking Bad you get to step in there
god damn that [ __ ] made King's
Speech look like goddamn what's-his-name
stepping inside the ring CM Punk I swear
to god [ __ ] King's Speech Colin
Firth's off [ __ ] Bryan Cranston make
that phone call to his wife about how I
did it and you had nothing to do with it
when the phone was tapped and Colin
Firth went like this
oh all right [ __ ] it I quit acting
that's what happened but yeah do it
I just [ __ ] can't believe good
television ah those [ __ ] haters out
there I could have done it it could have
done it you know how hard [ __ ] is how
about the fact that they're the people
that are that are doing it your little
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass huh how about that
they're the people that are doing it
when I say Oh Ozark is good or [ __ ]
Outsiders good yeah bro
oh yeah how about they did it how about
they did it yeah yeah but they did it
dude let's make this [ __ ] money even
though we can't right now cuz the
[ __ ] Rona anyway do it it's the
nighttime episode and we're killing it
I'll be I bet I've eaten so many kind
bars it's ridiculous that's what you got
to eat when you're [ __ ] just chill
and just kind
cuz they sound like they're maybe good
for you but they're definitely not cuz
they have so much sugar and I'm but I
still munch on those man only two three
of those he [ __ ] cookies and ice
cream I'm fat the other day I said to my
girl I go like this y'all [ __ ] it I'm
gonna be a fat guy she goes you can't be
fat and I go like this just [ __ ] Tommy
comes out like I was holding it in the
whole time bro I'll be a fat guy gotta
keep that body moving though man I
didn't work out my legs today and then
sat down to do my podcast so tomorrow
I'm gonna pull my back you know how it
goes dude I'm gonna work out real hard
did I stretch know that I sit down right
after my workout yup so tomorrow when I
wake up first things first so I pull my
back since and straight hit it wrong hit
it wrong hit it too soon yes hit the
[ __ ] sensational too soon yes dude
[ __ ] ruin the timing of the whole
thing dude I got a multipack you know
how [ __ ] dumb and dork you look when
you have a multipack when you have a
multipack and you're hanging out with
the [ __ ] phone and also the [ __ ]
thing and you're just like where it
going and it's my buddy has it my Irish
buddy keeps it in his pocket and a cord
comes out and it's always like swangin
and he's just like oh where we going and
I'm like do you ever charge your phone
he's like all because it's the iPhone -
oh I gotta plug it in there looking like
he's a [ __ ] robot just looks like
he's charging himself and the phones the
battery pack but yeah dude this is the
[ __ ] quote from Theodore Roosevelt
that I was saying so poorly that I was
my version of this is so poor what I
just said about Breaking Bad or The
Outsider this is an awesome quote it's
from Theodore Roosevelt Roosevelt
[ __ ] whatever dude take a note
god damnit we're removing o--'s from
Theodore Roosevelt [ __ ] or its Roosevelt
so which one is it dude I know you're
dead but whatever figure it out I'll do
it have your [ __ ] family your heirs
figure it out they're still named to
Roosevelt right
Roosevelt this is it it's called the man
in the arena I don't know why this quote
is called something
that's a real [ __ ] to be like hey dude I
put out a quote and it's called this
another quotes the quote but it's called
the man in the arena it is not the
critic who counts not the man who points
out how strong the man how the strong
man dit up dude let me start over
because I don't want to bastardize this
[ __ ] the man in the arena
it is not the critic who counts not the
man who points out how the strong man
stumbles or where the doer of Deeds
could have done them better the credit
belongs to the man who is actually in
the arena whose face is marred by dust
and sweat and blood who strives
valiantly who airs who comes short again
and again who spends himself in a worthy
cause Who at the best knows in the end
the triumph of high achievement and who
at the worst if he fails at least fails
while daring greatly so that his place
shall never be with those cold and timid
souls who neither know victory nor
defeat
even if they fart made up the last part
but still you know what dude that's
awesome
and I read that and I was like you know
what respect to all there's some [ __ ]
out there I don't like like their shows
out there I don't like there's [ __ ]
restaurants I don't like whatever it is
dude if they're making money get that
money [ __ ] me dude [ __ ] me [ __ ] me man
oh I don't like your restaurant piss on
me dude straight up not cuz I like it I
don't like it you're in the arena
[ __ ] cafe I don't like your food I'm
judging bro
but that's you know I love that quote I
love that quote that has a title we do
in breaks oh manscaped if you're bored
in the house why not play with your
balls dude I do it they tell my future
our sponsor today manscaped is here to
make sure your balls
our smooth while you or your partner are
playing with them manscaped promotes
clean hygiene when it comes to shaving
your balls thanks to their lawn mower
3.0 bed scape is the only men's brand
dedicated to below the waist grooming
and hygiene I groom every now and then
just trim a little bit of off the sides
you know sometimes my my [ __ ] likes to
you know pulse out like it's trying to
take a break from my penis but also meet
it back at the tip the perfect package
3.0 kit comes with the new and improved
lawn mower 3.0 water proof cordless body
trimmer and the ton of other liquid
formulations to round out your
manscaping routine this third generation
trimmer features a cutting edge ceramic
blade to prevent manscaping accidents
and it does do it
I don't Nick my nuts so go and check out
everything that they have when you
purchase the new perfect package 3.0 kit
at manscape comm you get the biggest
bang for your buck subscribers get a new
replacement blade refill for you dude
it's just awesome you get you get it
delivered to your door every three
months get 20% off free shipping get 20%
off in free shipping with the code
babies at manscaped comm that's 20% off
with the free shipping at manscaped calm
and use code babies make playing with
your balls the best part of your day
that thanks manscaped roman most guys
have tried different ways to last longer
but saying the Pledge of Allegiance in
your head or counting backwards from 10
doesn't always work what I used to do is
either think of for real
cartoons or a baseball never worked
still splurt it anyway um I didn't have
this back then when I was losing my gin
Roman swipes are a clinically proven way
to last longer in bed they're effective
easy to use and fast-acting but don't
require a prescription Roman can ship
swipes to you in discreet unmarked
packaging and its really cool they're
called Roman swipes and they're the
secret to longer-lasting sex you just
swipe them on you and you go
anga - thank you - thank you - thank at
a dangler dangler get $10 off your first
order of swipes and free two-day
shipping at get
and calm slash babies that's get Roman
dot-com slash babies for $10 off and
free two-day shipping get Roman dot-com
slash babies so yeah do it you hear
about what's going on in the news lately
kidding I don't even know why I don't
even know you know you hear what's going
on in the news lately you hear about
it's good out of the news lately a lot
of stuffs good out of the news lately I
got this carota virus going around
people try to dodge the rotavirus by
weird face shields and masks and we also
got a lot of stuff code out of the
Academy here they also got a lot of
stuff going out of battle
but uh Kanye beeps now he doesn't use
[ __ ] words this guy is just this is
on Rolling Stone Kanye takes to beeping
at his friends calling words the lowest
forms of communication it's amazing how
much I think
well of course crazy about Elsa respect
it and I got to start doing that I got
to just look at Bryan Callen and be like
pee pee beep beep beep beep beep beep he
says for the time being Kanye West seems
done with man-made construct constructs
like time-space money and most likely
the detriment of those around him the
human language to the detriment of you
know he says I think words are one of
our most one of our lowest forms of
communication huh that's how I
communicate am i dumb just you know take
out the trash is way better than people
people being going on going on
what sorry take out the trash you don't
know my language left yet also you're
still communicating it's still saying
[ __ ] you just saying beep music sound
food dancing are nonverbal forms of
communication we get so wrapped up into
words
we got to make things that are
speechless we have to make things that
leave people speechless we have to make
things to the level where no one can say
anything that puts me out of a job wow
dude
ladies and gentlemen crystally a
people-people on paper I was literally
talking about this in my [ __ ] special
no pain about how if you're so offended
you just become somebody who just makes
sounds to not offend people people
boiling ah who got I go like that this
is what Kanye West is literally doing
also he's a rapper dude
how you gonna rap by beeping uh do you
know who's [ __ ] you know who's really
into this that means take out the trash
dude this is how scab man tells his wife
he wants to make love and she goes okay
God people who scat are [ __ ] terrible
scatting doesn't that mean [ __ ] on
someone's chest too or am i away no
Chris it doesn't oops
thought it did how to scat all these
guys gotta be dude oh no and of course
he's a wide and his hairs medium oh dude
the guy [ __ ] for show this is on dude
I didn't want to talk about this this
was something that popped up dude oh I
can't wait to play this hold on this guy
starts off just weed out you gotta have
the most confidence to scat that's for
sure
we do bad way bad even way too bad we
back I'm Ben Jones I'm a singer in a
musician and in this video I'm gonna be
teaching you a little bit about how to
scout scatting is the use of your voice
as an instrument dude that's how it goes
and then it goes like this
goodnight you've learned goodnight
that's the video you've learned scatting
is the way to use your voice as an
instrument
goodnight that's all for now that's all
you need to know about scatting and what
you do you create nonsense syllables
sounds nonsense syllables serifs half
words too kind of oh they go black and
white in the middle of him singing in
the middle of him talking they go black
and white over the [ __ ] over what
he's saying and he's going quietly and
these [ __ ] improvise what's good
let's go to a music scout developed kind
of in the third shouldn't of other
members of the band Scout develop
knowledge some would use man of soft
lala-lulu
some would use more dude anybody who
does this is not fit I guarantee you
there's no fit guy that's cats as a
matter of fact you don't have to be fat
but you don't work out and you're skinny
fat for real any guy who's cats would
lose would lose a fight here's the deal
if the whole world fought to the death
no weapons everybody who's scats dies
first just straight up
people come in literally duly doodley
doodley doodley doodley wheeler rude oh
choked out dude so bad I don't know just
don't scat you know dude I bit social
distancing with everyone only people
I've hugged is my family and Joe Rogan
sounds about right and I went to my
dad's
took the fam to my dads and moms and we
stayed apart they would've been hug I'm
like it's fine they're like no you know
there's 72 you know so I'm like okay I
get it
they don't even hold my kid I'm like
okay and and I was doing this thing that
would this is so my family dude I was
doing this thing cuz now that I'm
quarantined I don't get to go out and
and and run the block like I usually do
you know what I mean and go out and get
the coffee and get the [ __ ] [ __ ] from
Whole Foods or whatever the [ __ ] I'm
getting and just live a life I get their
[ __ ] be inside so I got I had noticed
I had spinach and I noticed I had tuna
cans of tuna and I was like I'm gonna
make a salad like my dad used to and
it's gonna be cute because my dad did it
I remembered and now my dad's gonna pass
salad instructions down to his [ __ ]
kid and maybe one day I'll pass that to
my child
and do you know what the salads that my
dad used to me always had lettuce and
also tuna fish in it and that's it I
think but I wasn't sure but I would do
it I will put the Italian dressing on it
and then I would eat the [ __ ] and then
when I went to my dad's place I said to
my dad hey Dad remember when you used to
make salads like when we were all
growing up for yourself cuz it was
healthy and [ __ ] and he goes like this
what do you mean and I said hey you know
I used to put like tuna in with the
spinach and [ __ ] and used to put like
salad dressing on it and he goes like
this
spinach and I was like dad you know how
you used to make [ __ ] salads for
lunch when we were growing up you know
what I'm talking about you used to make
salads growing up and he would be like I
mean yeah sometimes I would make a salad
and I said alright well what'd you put
in it he said well I don't know it
depends on what I wanted in it and I was
like dad there was a specific kind of
[ __ ] salad that you would make that
you'd put tuna in it do you remember
putting tuna in your salad and he said
yeah and I said okay so what would be in
it and he said well I didn't put spinach
in it and I said okay what's in it and
he said well I would put like a ruger or
some other kind of leave in it I said
okay and what else and he said it
depends Tomatoes I said okay and what
else
sometimes olives and I said this is what
I'm [ __ ] asking dude this is
what I'm asking you why did it have to
be a [ __ ] argument why did we have to
be said goddamn Italian before you
answered it spinach I don't know you
know hey I'm over here making salads
that he's got to bust my balls you
coming on me who wants to know I'm
asking about a [ __ ] salad I'm his son
I was trying to make it cute I was
trying to be cute and tell you I [ __ ]
did it like you then you're gonna be
cute even though I'm 40 it's still cute
dude I did it all by myself
and one day I'll [ __ ] let my kid do
it but you [ __ ] it all up by being
like I mean nah you know I plan on the
middle and my mom was like yeah you used
to make [ __ ] salad you don't remember
you put the [ __ ] tuna in it I'm like
why is she even involved just Tony what
the [ __ ] you put the salad in what you
put [ __ ] his salad man he knows dude
he [ __ ] knows man
my dad dad's it up man my dad dad's it
up so hard it's unbelievable
one time I was talking to my my dad was
watching a movie when I was a kid and I
was with my brother and he was like you
like this movie is this a great movie
and I said yeah it's pretty 8 I said
it's pretty 80s and he said huh I said
it's 80s and he says oh huh and I said
all right what's the [ __ ] problem man
what and he goes like this I just don't
know what you mean and I said you don't
know what I mean by saying the movies in
the the movies in the 80s and he says oh
oh oh oh I thought you were saying a DS
and I said like a and D the letter and
he said no he said yeah I said no
[ __ ] 80s the movies 80s and he goes
like this
oh oh oh oh and I sensed that he was
still confused and I said hey Dad what
don't you get and he said well what's a
tease me and my brother were like a
tease you [ __ ] a DS and then [ __ ]
his second guess was a tease dink dink
dink [ __ ] what are you what is going
on he was only like [ __ ] 55 back then
if I did that now at 72 you're just what
cannot compute families funny as [ __ ]
huh my mom's just going nuts you know my
dad's going nuts
everyone's going nuts man everyone gets
older they get so [ __ ] nuts not me
dude keeping it real sane and
level-headed
keeping it real sane and level-headed
man you know what else I started
watching is the Sopranos I watched the
[ __ ] a pilot episode and I've seen
Sopranos I seen like three seasons The
Sopranos and then I like gave up I got
to start watching it again by the way I
tried Game of Thrones I did Game of
Thrones I did three four seasons dude
I'm out I'm out too much Brown and
nobody [ __ ] ever cracks a joke the
[ __ ] out of here get out of here there
needs to be humor in some [ __ ] I know
I've said this before but dude Game of
Thrones
nobody's gonna trip ever nobody's gonna
do some clunky [ __ ] [ __ ] out of here and
there's that much brown in it [ __ ] out
of here put colors in it
no pink [ __ ] out of here um so yeah but
Kanye beeps and I say I'm gonna start
scatting dude I should start scan' I
should scat on Instagram live is what I
should do I'm gonna do that just put
spent [ __ ] days kind of just chillin
looking at my son he's so cute dude you
know he just chills they just they just
chill babies are always just kind of
doing they always look like they're
[ __ ] busting and not you know just
like babies always looked at their
Boston and they just drool how about a
baby's day how about a baby's life a
baby's day dude they just wake up at
like [ __ ] 3:30 a.m. like their
goddamn ninety years old or a Navy SEAL
and they're just like okay turn to just
be [ __ ] annoying probably loud a lot
of the time okay they just wake up and
they just go like this
imagine if that just stuck with you the
rest of your life
babies just wake up and just go hmm this
is a really big crib and then the
[ __ ] old people older than you come
in they're like what's up what's going
on you want to eat they go here here eat
this burp just spitting oh [ __ ] hold me
up and fall in [ __ ] face just alright
you know that's the day for the baby and
then two and a half hours go by again
and then it's just like you're just like
Oh for [ __ ] sake given a bottle sit up
you [ __ ] [ __ ] dude they're just
you know how many times my babies like
this
what do you do you possessed straighten
the [ __ ] up dude this is this is
oppressing my baby right here and I'm
like what do you do and I try to and
then I try to [ __ ] move them and he
does this work the neck [ __ ]
dude I give you tummy time work the neck
[ __ ] on the tummy too much you hungry
and I just want to roll over doing it
I'm all good man the [ __ ] is wrong with
you man figure it out it's been two
months man I did I can't [ __ ] do
something for two months man people will
put me out babies day dude sometimes you
can't figure out what the [ __ ] it wants
cryin do it that's we all got to start
crying more man you
get your way give her in a relationship
see a lot of guys will be like that's
where I can't take it you know I give my
girl a lot of [ __ ] when she starts
crying then it's all all hands on deck
guy I apologize that's what it's gotta
be oh yeah bro oh yeah you try to
[ __ ] apologize and how about that how
about that that's always in my back
pocket dude
that's always in my back pocket is me
apologizing if you got that in your back
pocket then the sorry can be for you
understand what I'm saying hey [ __ ] you
this is that this I don't know and
that's why you're just like this and the
good thing I'm so sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry
well yeah like that and then you just
pull this [ __ ] well yeah I just I don't
know I just because it's good and then
she's oh I'm so sorry and then you got
that [ __ ] bro
that's that cry check phone um yeah but
you got that always in your back pocket
girls think that tell dude um girls
think that they got the [ __ ] bet last
move guys had the last move a guy crying
[ __ ] that dude you got the last move
take that iPad take that iPad um sorry
one fire is doing really dumb [ __ ]
texting me something that he should be
texting you and that is making me
goddamn irate and it's crazy to feel the
blood boil up now baby I'm gonna let you
in on some real time [ __ ] the connection
went away for one fire and he did not
text me he texted my my associate here
hey we lost the connection oh yeah dude
well I'm doing a [ __ ] podcast [ __ ]
so what did you tell her
one fire dude I'm just like over here
trying to learn about scattin man Oh
hard chibi chibi Bobby
Budi Budi dude and other dude and ooh I
feel like that's the [ __ ] cop-out one
shabadoo du Loup that's the cop-out one
let's look at this one how to sing jazz
scat sing oh I don't like chick scatters
I guess makes more sense to me I guess
no matter if there's girls doing it
there's gonna be guys doing it no matter
what if there's girls doing it there's
gonna be guys doing it no matter what
because guys are gonna try and get those
girls pussy's who are doing it so if a
girl's butt about a we pop up at a pub a
guys right there like did you know what
about if we bought butter book would you
like to see my backlight um so yeah
anyway everyone pick up scat okay you
know something else that I've been doing
a lot is blue apron it's so great
especially now I've been doing blue
apron cooking home cooking matters now
more than ever with blue apron you can
have peace of mind by getting fresh
quality ingredients delivered straight
to your door so you can cook delicious
easy meals in the comfort of your home
blue apron takes the guesswork out of
dinner and we mean more than just
deciding what to eat okay you can know
your ingredients are being prepared and
packaged with the highest attention to
quality and safety and with their
commitment to transparency and reducing
waste blue apron has your back in more
ways than one choose from a variety of
chef's designed ready to cook meals with
perfectly portioned ingredients and lots
of flavorful options all sent to your
door
prices start as low as seven dollars and
49 cents per serving what that's crazy
low blue apron is flexible skip weeks or
cancel anytime let blue apron take care
of meal planning so you can enjoy
everything else and that's important you
know over half of their signature menu
is stacked with ready to cook meals
designed for balanced eating they got
spinach and goat cheese stuffed pork
roast with shot
icky and warm farro salad YUM dude
grass-fed New York strip steaks with
mushrooms pork chorizo tacos I'm Spanish
find comfort in the kitchen with blue
apron and enjoy delicious home-cooked
meals check out this week's menu and
visit blue apron calm that's blue apron
calm blue apron feed your soul the last
degree of Kevin Bacon it's a new Spotify
original podcast I love Kevin Bacon
Kevin Bacon is so cool I think he's one
of the coolest movie stars that there's
ever been and this is a fictional comedy
podcast from Spotify and Funny or Die
called the last degree of Kevin Bacon
and that's very cool to me the premise
of the show is that 36 years ago a guy
named Randy B's lo narrowly lost the
starring role in Footloose to Kevin
Bacon and has been obsessed with him
ever since so Randy has finally hit his
breaking point and vows to go to LA kill
his enemy and replace him in the
universe sounds like it's right up my
alley but guess what things don't quite
go as planned though when he gets a
thing things don't quite go as planned
when he gets there the word though
shouldn't be in that sentence and that's
100 extreme percent extreme is obvious
because what exactly do you do when your
mortal enemy just wants you to be his
best friend that's what Kevin Bacon
wants because he's a nice guy the last
degree of Kevin Bacon stars
no-nothing Kevin Bacon Keira Cedric is
in it too Matt Walsh from veep plays
Randy B's low tweeted him once he never
tweeted back lamorne Morris stars in the
show as well we love lamorne over here
babies love lamorne and it features Rob
Reiner Emily Deschanel Rhea Perlman
Natalie Morales a bunch of people Terry
Gross Michaela Watkins it's gonna be
hilarious so check it out the last
degree of Kevin Bacon is a Spotify
original podcast and you can listen to
it for free only on Spotify if you
haven't listened to my Netflix if you
haven't watched my Netflix special yet
go check it out what are you waiting for
no pain it's out there on on Netflix
appreciate you guys um you know
appreciate you know whatever it's all
good but
I don't know man we're flying by the
seat of our pants I've been looking at
these workout video because I work out
now by in my garage I kind of go to the
gym and I just kind of do my workouts
and I noticed Men's Health asked me if I
wanted to do one of their workout videos
and men's health and I was like [ __ ]
gasps sign me up and then I was like
wait a minute how do I do it though
because the camera crew is we can't do
it at my gym because of the coronavirus
I was like did they just does a camera
crew come to my house and I work on my
garage and they were like no you'd shoot
it yourself and send it to them and
they'll cut it together and I go like
this by I'm not gonna do it my [ __ ]
self dude so I've been looking at these
videos I love the videos I think the men
cells put together some cool [ __ ] and
then I went into other videos that were
like less professional and why don't any
of these Marvel actors or actors that
are getting jacked for movies the
whether it be the rock or anybody the
videos should just be here's how [ __ ]
the rock gets jacked here's how Hugh
Jackman got jacked for Logan and then a
guy comes on he's like hi this is how
Hugh Jackman got jacked for Logan
steroids D'Antoni
don't think don't rent a thin thin thin
thin thin and Hugh Jackman just fly
doing doing freeze frame bicep curl
staying on that thing only enough
[ __ ] guarantee only a ripping pimp
they use steroids that's why they look
like a painting bro I workout so [ __ ]
hard and your boy eats every now and
then slipped up a little bit tonight ate
some eggplant parmesan but it was yummy
and bro I work out hard as [ __ ] dude I
go hard I keep my brow furrowed and I'm
always in Kiba dachi
and that means horse stance in Japanese
dude I'm multicultural and so I do that
[ __ ] and I'm sweating hey you boys got
some [ __ ] ABS but your boys not
looking like the rock
he boys not looking like Hugh Jackman
and in Logan your boys not looking like
[ __ ] Chris Evans and Captain America
or even Chris Pratt in guardians of the
galaxy do you know why cuz they're
cycling they're using roids dude why is
that not something why are there even
making those videos well here's what a
lot to do Hugh Jackman's life is what a
lot to do you know I go hey I do
deadlifts and then I run on the
treadmill for an hour and then I'll do
deadlifts and then I [ __ ] do more
deadlifts and then I do a deal like a
[ __ ] chesty exercise he's my trainer
he's bald and he's not even really he's
a lot of phase gut fit the trainer's
that they got they're always like fat a
little bit he's fat he's balding he's
fat but he's my trainer thanks to him
thanks to him are we are and there was
something else I was forgetting also
thanks to steroids and and guess what
though dude and I'm telling you right
now this ain't [ __ ] I'm doing a
[ __ ] movie it's not in the
foreseeable future yet but dude say I
won't be in an action movie first of all
I got one coming out called army the
dead your boy [ __ ] your boy [ __ ]
what where you going where you going
that's me where you going that's me bro
you saying I don't look legit where you
going
put that down put that down put that
down okay that's your boy and I'm all
geared up from the feet up I got [ __ ]
full clothes on because I play a
helicopter pilot so I'm in an action
movie coming out whether you like it or
not okay when I really get the shit's
when I'm really with the shit's dude
when your boys sliding over [ __ ] car
roofs on his ass
and the jackets picking out the back
when your boys got one [ __ ] gun in
one hand and the other hand
loosey-goosey cuz he needs to slide over
the [ __ ] hood of the car with the
jacket peeking out the back say I won't
say I won't walk slow-motion walls
[ __ ] our car explodes in the
background say I won't not look back say
I won't not look back your boy will do
it and when your boy does it and when
your boy works out real hard for that
role your boy is also gonna be doing
steroids and that's no joke and I can't
wait til somebody says so how'd you get
fit you know as if Jay Leno is still a
thing so how do you get fit for the
wrong you know steroids Jay Bam Bam rim
fam man mmm you flexing the mirror
[ __ ] lats looking like a turtle red
then Anton ran out there zooming in a
[ __ ] of the whole movie was shot on my
back rent a 10 there and pam-pam it's
not you know it is maybe if you [ __ ]
[ __ ] it dude that's the [ __ ] man when
your boys really with the shit's I'm
doing steroids when the [ __ ] goes down
well I don't give a [ __ ]
gap-toothed Baldus [ __ ] jacked like a
turtle and moving slow too cuz my joints
hurt yeah do it I will do steroids can't
wait just getting so mad at my girl
where's the chicken I gotta eat the
chicken [ __ ] now I got a tow after I
[ __ ] work out I gotta eat it now
she's like what's wrong just see and see
in the back of my throat with my teeth
closed cuz the [ __ ] gap is so big you
could buy a cable knit sweater in it
[ __ ] it do it I'm doing it all
and you are too dude that's what this
podcast is about coming together this is
a cult coming together in this cult and
when I take steroids I'm being honest
with you babies I haven't yet I haven't
even taken whatever they call it I have
any kind of thing some guy came up to
the gym a you taking tea or some
testosterone your boy goes all natural
man and it's hard but when that movie
comes along well they want you to all
take steroids don't worry thinking if
you'd like to make a call please hang
out Perry I make bigger [ __ ] tant's
dude what is this a [ __ ] penis dude
that's how big my penis is I sort of got
ya bro you know I got to start doing
anyway dude that the workout celeb the
videos are hilarious we do six sets of
[ __ ] chin-ups and then six sets of
the things yeah yeah okay cool and then
you [ __ ] shoot up in your [ __ ]
anyway watch my Netflix special Oh God
loving it well I mean we're on fires
laughing dude what the [ __ ] are you
watching aw he's probably watching some
[ __ ] not doing his job bro I got to
start doing it's so cool when I drag the
[ __ ] yes dude I got the [ __ ] thing
I got the thing the keymap where I get
to [ __ ] do you know all these things
I can't make it come back that's awesome
dude
I love when that happens on computers
how about when that happens when that
happens I go nuts when you can't I got
it um anyway life reps dude and you got
a guy to [ __ ] remember that man and I
shout out to all you guys doing what you
can a lot of people are filing for
unemployment man I feel you
you gotta get those government checks it
was cool that we were gonna get those
you know that you're gonna get the
government checks and then Trump was
like hold on wait a second I wanted to
take a little bit longer because I want
to autograph each one what a [ __ ]
dick dude hey man just give him the
money okay hey Trump you don't need to
sign it just given the money the money
is not from you you're just president
you happen to be President I can't wait
to see this Biden Trump
go down man can't wait I can't wait to
see this Biden Trump thing from just
gonna be like well you're a [ __ ]
you're a piece of [ __ ] and then Biden's
gonna be like are you sure oh that's
gonna be the [ __ ] debate and you're
gonna be like you can't call him a piece
of [ __ ] and Biden why'd you say you ate
a churro and then the bullet is gonna
[ __ ] a little bit what is this world
coming to
dude we're all [ __ ] maybe China
[ __ ] the people the lab in China made
the made the virus now it's what they're
saying that's what they're maybe saying
who knows I guess I'm gonna wrap things
up though you guys are really great and
I love that you're listening and thank
you very much it's been about 55 minutes
right we're okay and you guys are great
I'm gonna do these podcast maybe at
night I find all the syllables at night
but this is the nighttime podcast from
now on I might still do daytime ones
depending on the schedule but you know I
might do nighttime once more really guys
thank you so much for listening
I really thank you very much for
watching my special on Netflix I love
that you're watching it and watch it
some people told me that someone could
tell me they were watching it eight
times in a row now is that too many yes
do you have no life yes but we all have
no life yes why because there's a
pandemic all right so it's all good you
guys thank you very much and I got
nothing else to say to you guys for this
week but next week tune into
congratulations podcast the podcast and
leave a review you know it really helped
text me eight one eight two three nine
seventy eighty seven and you can support
the show by buying merch at store Chris
D'Elia calm and
you can get gift cards - for other
people and [ __ ] - anyway I'm also off
[ __ ] social media you don't even
bother tweeting me man I don't need to
see it I mean it's whatever I don't look
it's a it's all good you guys are graded
I appreciate you guys thank you very
much
[Music]
so now what